I have been on the NRA Russia story for
months
I interviewed vivica Novak almost two
months ago at this point we talked to
her about how she and her team at
McClatchy DC have been covering the
story and following the story it really
wasn't getting almost any media
attention at the time our interview with
her clearly struck a chord over a
hundred thousand views on YouTube
hundreds of emails about it and slowly
the story kept building the NRA would
say sort of vague and bizarre things
that they weren't really explanations
they were pseudo denials very weak
denials and that over the last 24 hours
now the NRA has admitted to sort of what
is one of the key points of the story
which is yeah the NRA actually has been
receiving money from foreign entities
and then what they do with that money is
sort of move it between accounts and
they are claiming of course that they do
it legally and it's that moving of money
between accounts that allows them to
hide the specific origins of money
that's used for political purposes and
we learned this from a letter that they
wrote to Democratic Senator Ron Wyden
and they're not at least yet admitting
specifically to all of the allegations
that have been made by McClatchy and
vivica Novak's team about money coming
from Russia going through the NRA and
then being pumped into Donald Trump's
2016 election but it does get us several
steps closer to proving that and we'll
see if we ultimately do prove it and in
fact for now the NRA straight-up denying
the Russia connection specifically they
are saying in their letter to Ron Wyden
we do receive foreign money none of that
money is connected to Russia and of
course by that they might mean it's not
connected to the Russian government but
we already know from vivica Novak's
reporting that this appears to be from
Russian oligarchs who are Kremlin
connected so again it becomes a semantic
game and the NRA also saying to Ron
Wyden in their letter to him that none
of the contributions were made in
connection
with US elections which is grammatically
an almost completely meaningless
statement and there is one reason I can
think of why they would even make this
admission right so you might be saying
well okay if they've been denying this
entirely for weeks or even months at
this point why would they write a letter
to Ron Wyden and even admit to this and
there's sort of two possibilities the
most likely one to me is that they're
trying to get ahead of something we
don't yet know what but this is a story
that has been of more and more interest
to investigative journalists and the NRA
may have learned that someone is getting
close the other possibility is that they
are trying to prevent Ron Wyden who's
been paying very close attention to this
from looking further into it but I think
Wyden is looking into this period so my
supposition would be they might be
admitting to this because they're trying
to get ahead of whatever it is that's
about to happen now I what I really want
to get into it the meat of this for me
is the sort of mechanism that they are
talking about here to defend themselves
the NRA is allowed to receive foreign
money right but they're not allowed to
use foreign money to influence elections
in the United States that would be
illegal that would violate campaign
finance law so the NRA isn't telling us
how are they moving money around
internally but they are assuring us in
this letter to Ron Wyden that no foreign
money was used for electioneering only
legal domestic money was used for
influencing elections including the 2016
election of Donald Trump this is the
same argument that the right rejects at
face value
when Planned Parenthood uses this
argument or when defenders of Planned
Parenthood use this argument I'll
explain
Republicans say you can't use federal
money for abortions so we shouldn't fund
Planned Parenthood and Planned
Parenthood will always come back and say
listen 97% 98% of what we do isn't
related to abortion services none of the
abortion services are funded by the
federal funds we get we
other money from donations from people
other sources of money to fund the
abortion services and what the right
will say is come on money is homogeneous
money is fungible there is no way of
knowing whether you're using federal
funding for abortion related services
because all money is money ultimately
dollars are dollars and you can move
them around that's the exact same thing
here right same argument could apply to
student loans you're only allowed to use
student loan money on school related
expenses great so all of a sudden you
don't use your personal money for school
stuff you use your student loan money
for school stuff but that frees up quote
personal money for things like travel
and electronics or whatever I guess
you're sort of technically not using the
loan money for the travel and the
PlayStation but you're freeing up
personal money because of the loan money
that you did get it tells us nothing at
all period and from a sort of forensic
accounting and legal perspective you can
make the case that there's really no
difference between the NRA s political
funds and their non political funds if
the NRA is commingling the money and
moving it back and forth between
political and non-political accounts
that's going to be again if an
investigation gets going for the
forensic accountants to sort out but
long story short it's yet another
example of how more of that story has
been proven true with every passing week
we get closer to verifying the McClatchy
DC story that vivek anova novak told us
about and we'll see ultimately how much
more we learn about this the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership